PlayStation is leaping into the world of
prosumer controllers with the Dual sense
Edge we have the opportunity to check
out the new Gamepad and it feels like a
well-rounded hobbyist controller that's
easy to customize on the Fly the Dual
sense Edge feels and looks nearly
identical to the Dual sense controller
which the lead product manager assured
me was an intentional decision so as to
not alienate players who have already
spent hundreds of hours with the
standard dual sense the customizable
back buttons are the thing that felt the
most different unlike the Xbox Elite
Series 2 controllers 4 there are only
two back buttons on this controller the
paddles jut out slightly more than the
elite controllers meaning it requires a
tap to press rather than the squeeze
motion you would normally do with an
elite controller the package also comes
with an alternative set of back buttons
shaped like half Moons these felt more
natural in our hands as they leaned
right up against our middle fingers of
course you can also remove all the back
buttons altogether if you'd like there
are limits to what you you can and can't
customize when it comes to button
configurations you cannot program
multiple inputs to a single button press
and there are some restrictions with the
touchpad though we didn't get a good
idea of those during the preview the
most useful additions to the Dual sense
Edge are the two function buttons
located just below the analog sticks
holding one down brings up a menu that
allows you to quickly switch controller
profiles adjust headset volume and pop
into a menu to tweak your controller
settings the function buttons feel like
a natural extension of the Dual sense
that makes it easier to access key
features you're likely to need in a
gaming session their location makes them
hard to miss click during heated moments
yet they are easy to access mid-game the
biggest barrier for us when it comes to
controller customization has always been
finding the time to really fine tune it
to fit our needs but the Dual sense Edge
makes it a breeze to find and test
different controller settings the Sleek
new controller menu is also effortless
to navigate once you've created a
profile you can customize button
assignments stick and dead zone
sensitivities trigger dead zones
vibration intensity and Trigger effect
intensity if you flip on the trigger
stops it will automatically adjust
trigger effect sensitivity from the
stick sensitivity Dead Zone menu you can
pick from a handful of default
sensitivity curves for sticks or you can
tweak the sensitivity and dead zone
manually there's a handy visualizer in
this menu as well that shows how much
force you're putting on the sticks with
your preferred settings along with
swapping out the stick caps the Dual
sense Edge also allows you to remove the
stick modules you can pop off the hood
with the little tab on the back of the
controller from there you can unlock the
modules and push them out historically
the sticks on controllers are usually
the first to go so this Edition is a
welcome one the modules run from twenty
dollars on Sony's official storefront
Which is far more reasonable than
purchasing a new controller outright
popping the hood off was a bit of a pain
but ideally you shouldn't have to do
that often annoyingly the hood itself is
made out of a glossy plastic that
attracts smudges and thumb prints in the
few hours we had with the controller we
found it impossible to keep it clean
this certainly isn't a deal breaker but
it will surely be enough to bother some
users hopefully because the hood can be
removed entirely we will see some
aftermarket hoods with a matte finish
while the Dual sense Edge probably won't
cater to Casual PlayStation 5 owners
it's a great piece of kit for those who
take their gaming seriously during our
time with the controller we tested out
God of War Ragnarok Call of Duty Modern
Warfare 2 and Gran Turismo 7. between
the three we found the Dual signs Edge
best suited for modern warfare's Twitchy
gameplay being able to map jump and
slide to the back buttons meant we
didn't have to take our Thumb off the
right analog stick while performing some
of the game's trickier Maneuvers
meanwhile the controller didn't feel as
useful for Gran Turismo 7 and God of War
Ragnarok it's nice being able to map
things to the back buttons but the
appeal of the Dual sense Edge isn't
quite as strong for single player games
where inputs are fewer and the demands
of the player are much less than in a
competitive multiplayer experience like
the elite the controller along with the
charger swappable stick cabs back
buttons and a cord lock are all packaged
in a white hard shell carrying case with
a hole in the back for easy charging
overall the Dual sense Edge feels like a
nice option for PlayStation owners that
might have been looking at Xbox's
offerings with Pro Controller Envy for
two hundred dollars you'll get a
controller that has a familiar form
factor improves ergonomics some new
feature options and a good level of
customization
[Music]
thank you
[Music]